Recall that we had this state
as a kind of hanging state.
It had no successes state.
And we said that, well this state can
be dismissed, but here is a question.
Who will dismiss it,
the generator or the tester?
What do you think, David?
So I think the tester would do it.
We could have the tester basically say
any state where there is only one person
on the side of the river that
has the boat can be pruned off,
because the only way to get into that
state is to send that person over.
And the only way to get out of that
state is to undo the previous move.
So my rule would be for the tester,
any time only one person is
on the side of the river with the boat,
throw out that state.
>> What does everyone else think?
Is David right about this?